hey guys Ryan right here Dan cyber here
and we're gonna watch the trailer for
not the trailer yeah the trailer the
trailer we're gonna watch the gameplay
trailer but 4 farcry 4 farcry 4 b 3 1 e
3 1 yeah yeah a little hungover it's
just a little bit head hurt a little
real rejects party last night woke up to
discover everyone else slept over Jim
Barry with good times we saw the trailer
for far cry 4 yeah but we haven't seen
the gameplay trailer yeah we saw the
first sequence in the game actually oh
yeah it was a cool tree I was the one
that was like passport please passport
yeah that best dub and yet let's watch
this trailer go let's nurse our hangover
I'm ready my body
creative director of [ __ ] rifle hello
I'll go with far Christ create beautiful
exotic and dangerous locations filled
them with weapons vehicles and toys and
let you create your own story this year
with far cry 4 we invite you to visit
her at a country soaked in secret
history filled with weaponized animals
and ruled by an eccentric despot weapon
I love animals whenever I think of
weaponized
animals always think of like a cat with
a minigun strapped to its back oh that's
not what's gonna be at all but still Wow
oh it's Gameboy I didn't realize this
gameplay right it's the key
I like regular it's like this characters
walking incredibly smooth it's a pretty
quick go check it out Matt explosion
here we go
was very detailed yeah that's what
they're watching
okay let's remember that Jesus we're
square but we're learning the controls
and hey beginner gonna remember that
looks like fun I love it it really feels
like they're from this like first-person
toward your feet yeah it's not not just
a good game point I've got this an urge
this is one of those games you could
like watch your friend oh absolutely
be like so good lot sneaky stuff
Oh Roscoe that's pretty cool pretty
badass looking crossbow to hospitals
with [ __ ]
oh oh oh sweet oh my god I'm amazing
so let's recover them yeah this guy's
the [ __ ] square button there's a lot of
that must be reaction
ah yes yes you that was amazing so cool
it's like the beginning of the year
ah I'm clear I'm clear when this happens
oh nice damos like a real movement is
badass this looks like a ton of fun [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
fighting is not a good temper
look at my arm
this guy has no fear
dude I would be pissing my pants I would
not know how to deal with him see this
is crazy
now are you like choosing to go on this
path or is it is this the one half I
have no idea I'm assuming since it was a
broad slide that helped taking this
place down
Burke back me up someone call for a
shirt a gyrocopter oh this is the multi
player
in English
and it's [ __ ] light everything up
- this games
you do a lot of crazy shits like
relaxing
all right right in the middle of the
middle of the crowd everyone
oh those nice answer
all the program
this eventually
those elephants are doing like
afterwards okay oh cool
look
well [ __ ]
awesome
very impressive very impressive game
very impressive it's like a first-person
Metal Gear meet not halo called it Call
of Duty first-person shooter called it
yes because unless shits crazy it's kind
of kind of a sneaking game yeah I mean I
started playing the first very first
park ride which is pretty hard to play
you know you get used to next-gen
controls and smoothness and then you go
back and play like old second just like
what is happening but yeah there is
definitely a degree of stealth that
plays into these games it looks like a
lot of fun I would love to do all those
things in real life I'm just hoping that
is not gonna be complicated to do all
that stuff it looks pretty simple you
just press the square button just press
the square button action the whole game
it's just a square foot no caves just
square the only selection I saw oh well
thank you for recommending that trailer
to a game does look it just wrestle it
applies that it looks good looks great
usually if cinematic graphics are
amazing the gameplay is usually not too
bad so yeah eventually we'll get used to
the next-gen graphics of this and the
neck the gen after that we're all gonna
go oh my god blows max blows up man
ma'am ma'am they're video games they be
blown Armand thank you
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects or or
maybe and ah how about you and he'll do
and and yeah and and is possible you can
subscribe to dance channel as well as
gaming channel yeah or just lets plays
on there and other fun video game
related stuff Louis long go hey he would
like a shout-out Louie long go you know
where I'm going with this right yeah
long go what am i referring to it was
what is it your dick did your dick
belong go your dicks too long ago ah
mine is long ago that should be the
should have a talking penis and should
we call Louie in the long go coming the
Nickelodeon yeah all and they like solve
mysteries and stuff okay the worst part
about is I'm told
yeah Lilian bolongo actually SBU no no
no no no no but also would probably be a
great an adult adult swim show and what
it would would let's pitch it refractory
gin hey Ryan
I'm still waiting for a shout-out you
douchebag but still I love you keep up
the good work
well refractory gin you insulted me so
now I'm gonna insult you back your
mother sucks at sex are you implying
that sex with my that I had sex with his
mom and that she was terrible that she
actually was also horrible wasn't even
good like man makes sense why I came out
with idiots like refractory gin he also
gave your love so now now who gave him
it in Seoul a tough love my friend I
love you too though and I will continue
to keep up the good work to satisfy guys
like you mark daya hey hey Ryan I'm
reaching your channel and like your vids
keep with the good work bro also a shout
out will be superb thanks mark daya your
shout out is going to be superb right
now grab some teeth should we grab some
tea Michael we should grab some tea oh
we have a mock for you mister right
thank you oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
hot dessert what is wrong with you I
apologize mark daya you have been
initiated into the fan club of the real
rejects it is hard to be a member comes
with a lot of benefits dick jokes [ __ ]
jokes and a lot of Jewish and black
jokes cuz what better race to attack and
those guys in retrospect that shout-out
may have not been superb but it was an
initiation it was an initiation shower
yeah sorry I set the bar too high for
myself on that one man I was like you
know I was like I was trying
too hard because I was he said the
shoutout would be superb superb I [ __ ]
it up the shadow hey hey hey you got
there you got you brought him home
I like Blacks and Jews to sort of with a
black girl the others hey good